so I've heard that YouTube sends new
viewers to very strange places on
YouTube think about it there's millions
and millions of videos on YouTube how do
they know which ones to give to a new
viewer someone who's never been to the
site before someone who doesn't have an
account someone who doesn't know where
they're going how is the suggested
system gonna toss videos at them that's
the question
because I've heard that it's not just
weird places that they go onto YouTube
because there's some weird videos that I
know and love but sometimes it can send
new viewers to places like conspiracy
theory videos racist videos rants and
stuff like that it's like what I'm
curious is like if there's someone that
wants to find those videos that's fine
but I'm curious to see how soon YouTube
will send me to something terrible and
understand I'm not doing this very
scientifically I only have an incognito
window up I don't have like a VPN or
anything I didn't create a new account
I'm not on a new computer it's my same
internet but it seems like this home
page is a wide variety of just generally
speaking stuff it Hill oh yeah
Beauty is not so beautiful oh my god so
it seems like it's just a general loop
of this and and I can test this out by
if I click on this and then I click on
this I click on this Terry Crews
whatever if I go here to my home page my
home page will be different because now
it will suggest things to me it's got a
recommended list and recommended is when
it starts to think it knows what you
want and that's when things can start
going downhill but if I control a 5
suddenly my oh no I have to close ok
Google is a little stickier than I
thought it would be if I close the
window and open the window again
bada-bing bada-boom
I don't ever recommend it anymore and
then it's just an assortment of videos
that it doesn't think I know I want so
I'm gonna use this as my starting point
and and basically this video is gonna be
called like six degrees of separation
from bad videos or it's like how far
down the YouTube rabbit hole there are
until you get to [ __ ] videos or whatever
this video is gonna be called I don't
even know anymore but I'm gonna be the
determinant on what oh no don't wear wet
socks to bed don't do that no that's a
terrible idea
okay
I'm gonna start from somewhere innocent
somewhere relatively simplistic
somewhere that like shouldn't lead me to
anything bad right okay let's go ten
amazing homemade inventions which I
imagine is gonna be amazing it looks
like a swimming pool yeah it's um yeah
it's a it's a swimming pool I mean it's
a nice swimming pool I guess okay so
this is just a series of other people's
videos that have been ripped from here
so good for that all right free copper
bar from a microwave oven please don't
think this is gonna lead to minecraft of
some kind well that is some special that
is a slice of some special
that's real neato they're free copper so
it's a really easy job and it's and it's
fun so even getting your free copper the
process of getting it is fun too and
bang you've got copper ok well that went
places what is this next video what is
this how do we what the [ __ ] this isn't
even in my language I was looking at
English what is this why was this
suggested I don't even know what's
happening yeah okay wipe that [ __ ] up I
guess
Oh God Oh Oh God oh that's sexual oh you
just what's yes safety first okay that
makes sense I went for videos in I'm
already in a different language oh god
what is this okay oh and now I'm in
flower arrangements I don't know how I
got here what the [ __ ] is this
I'm just click on things that catch my
eye I'm not actively going anywhere here
I whoa whoa okay alright seems really
dangerous I don't know how I got the
bouzouki i de caza and your enamel on
this l you Stassi you sell our I don't
know how I got here what are you doing
oh I get it
it's a compilation of people working
quickly oh okay I'm still in the wrong
language what is that in your arty Farah
copani nasiha yah polier
what
zelich is this a better mousetrap is
that what this is
did you just make it wait no you made it
Coke and Pepsi just to get people
clicking on this because then you could
put Coke and Pepsi in here didn't some
[ __ ] baller music huh
yeah you did didn't you you wanted to
get those keywords in there I know what
you're doing here cuz I see in the
suggest an easy bird trap technology
make from Coca Cola and popsicle yeah I
don't care oh wow very impressive very
impressive okay first step one drink
your delicious cocka Co oh oh do it
slower hang on wait
no oh take another sip let me get a good
enjoyment out of this oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
slurp it down you need the popsicle - oh
wait let me get this in slow motion oh
whatever Google is doing to look at me
right now they are [ __ ] weirded out
but it is probably not the weirdest
thing that they've ever seen let's just
go back home I want to see how it's
changed
yeah record now I've got a recommended
oh boy yeah now I've got some
recommended and it Oh what is that I
don't know what is that that's horrible
oh my God look at the murder in this
man's eyes I've never seen wait three
two one murder
[Laughter]
suggested oh one of our most difficult
earwax removals I didn't want this house
Jim fails that person's dying holy [ __ ]
I don't even know how this happened okay
alright good God I still concerned in
this man and like you know I'm not
unconvinced that it's not murder because
look at what he's doing to this poor
poor guy I can't do that okay I can't do
that
alright yeah go back oh no oh god no no
my recommended is now Oh God
oh that's a splinter it's still not good
I don't like that mask
I don't like anything about this oh god
my recommended Tsar what is with these
five minute craft videos they're getting
44 million views I mean forget teasers
they've got like 20 this is the same
thing but they got like 20 languages and
they're not five minutes d'lai oh my god
oh yeah yeah wait wait
[ __ ] wait wait a minute hold your
goddamn horses you think you're just
gonna skate I don't want to know what
that is at all I don't want to know I
don't know where this went I don't know
how a guy got here but I don't want to
know what that is but you think that
calling for help
in a drowning type situation is this
maneuver it's like worse than animu god
no oh [ __ ] me yeah pants okay how do
pants fix this problem from panic to
cool calm and collected
it's like two steps it's like juice Oh
[Music]
right okay so so this lady right she
sees her friend drop she does a few
jumping jacks to start off grabs and
ears pair of pants ties off the legs
throws it in is to beat which drowning
woman would be able to catch a pair of
flying pants good question really good
question you know that is a good
question that's [ __ ] hilarious but
also this was published a week ago forty
four million views and I can see why I
could see why YouTube got me here this
is not content I want to see but I'm
here somehow I'm here I don't know how
I'm here oh wow
great what is this what is this oh wow
that was quite a logo I don't know what
he just said but it was probably very
very very something expression
no way okay wait but speaking of
disturbing material and I really want to
go down this rabbit hole because I think
this is the type of rabbit hole well
that'll get me to the conspiracy videos
but what the [ __ ] is this
[Music]
stop there are 8,000 people watching
this 8,000 people watching this and here
we are
oh okay all right I'm gonna forgive this
one cuz this was made in like 2017 and
that's when this type of content was at
its worst so I'm gonna assume that me
getting to it is not indicative of what
YouTube is trying to push on people it
has no [ __ ] clue what I want
I know YouTube is just panicking and
throwing literally anything at me that I
could possibly at all doc OH
oh god what is that it has no YouTube
has no idea what I want but this is what
they have to contend with I suppose
there's some about like in the video I
like I like a strong lady okay
alright let's see how that changed okay
I you know I'm very very confident in my
masculinity and I'm not intimidated but
oh my god okay so how long is it 20 up
and doing this for 20 minutes that's it
20 minutes 20 minutes to send my YouTube
recommended down a rabbit hole that
they'll never come back from this is
this is irreparable I mean even on my
account when I'm watching videos if I
watch one video
it's just instantaneously everything I
could possibly ever want for that type
of video but now it has no idea the
language is wrong like everything about
it is wrong like these life hack things
are wrong like one two three four five
five of the ten
recommended on this page are not English
like I know there's a diversity of
content on YouTube I get that and that's
what makes YouTube great understandably
it is what makes YouTube great that is
great about YouTube this so much that
people can upload but at the same time
holy [ __ ] how does anybody manage this
and I didn't even get to a conspiracy
theory video okay this is not what I
came to do so let's back out let's blitz
back up a few steps
alright I'm closing out of that one
because holy [ __ ] I have no idea what
was going on there but let's try this
again I'm hoping I'm hoping that when I
open up a fresh page it's gonna be a
clean slate is it a clean slate okay
it's a clean slate okay okay it's a
clean slate I think so that was just
with me going on the front page and I
went down around and honestly like I was
okay I was guiding it a little bit but I
want to see how many videos it takes to
get to a conspiracy theory video because
that was the original intention but I
mean it's going down YouTube rabbit
holes are [ __ ] weird so let's start
from somewhere safe I want to start with
somewhere very safe and we'll put up a
counter here of how many videos deep I
am until we get to where we're trying to
go for something flat earth or something
vaccination related something like 9/11
maybe related some kind of conspiracy
theory that's what I'm trying to get to
you know let's start with dangerous
biggest heavy-duty hammer forging that
sounds pretty cool I'd want to watch
that video I've never been more turned
on by a machine holy [ __ ] oh my god Oh
inventions you wouldn't believe if they
weren't recorded alright what are they a
truck I don't believe it I just don't
believe it a really shitty truck I have
refused to believe this unbelievable my
moments you wouldn't believe if they
were record I'm down I'm on believing I
don't believe it I can't believe these
moments oh [ __ ] well alright I can't
believe that moment the mystery of the
Holden Lake Barry Xie
four wonders among them is the
mysterious hole in Lake Berryessa then
Evan kilkis discovered something
unexpected and what he found inside was
truly outrageous uh-huh
are we is this technically in the
conspiracy theory genre because I think
we might actually whoa okay that's too
much please stop this might actually be
kind of conspiracy theory issues so in
the wake of the low water levels the
slipway was closed and eventually
forgotten now in most cases slipways
often run through sections of the dam
wall or over them but so it's a dam
slipway it's not it's not actually that
interesting Oh
the Bermuda Triangle mystery has been
solved has it now okay all right this
region is notorious for its mysterious
phenomenon right okay how many deep are
we we are this number deep five not that
deep okay here we go
what really happened to Malaysia
Airlines okay oh this is sad what is
this what is this Encyclopedia
Brittanica here why is this here why why
am I seeing this ooh
information from third parties alongside
videos on a small number of
well-established historical and
scientific topics have often subject to
misinformation online like the moon
landing ah so that's a way to fight
conspiracy theory videos that's
interesting ah YouTube has protection
against it neato burrito talk about
clickbait CNN is that really the plane
the nimitz encounter all strange events
that occurred on Southwest oh [ __ ] yeah
Oh give me some UFOs oh [ __ ] yeah we're
in UFO territory 10 things NASA doesn't
want you to know oh [ __ ] yeah babies
NASA doesn't Oh tell me number 10 whoa
drive technology forget the speed of
sound we could soon be boldly going past
the speed of light in the near future
with Star Trek style warp technology oh
wait oh wait okay if we didn't think
that we weren't actually in conspiracy
theory territory top-five artifacts that
true
of past advanced civilizations existed
Oh million year old rock a mysterious
gold man-made Bell encased in charcoal
for millions of years hundreds of small
spheres with tiny grooves dating back to
point eight billion years these proof of
past ancient advanced civilizations no
there's a very easy answer to this it's
shockingly easy the results from iron
smelting iron smelting alone leave
deposits in lake beds rivers all around
the world if we did have a civilization
before we were here we would know from
those records the geological records of
an advanced civilization creating iron
you cannot have a civilization until you
get through the Iron Age like it's just
how it is yeah anyway I'm not here to
disprove anything oh my God look at my
suggested feed Oh No we don't exist for
megalithic sites that would change the
history books it's amazing unsettling
discoveries that might change history
oh shut up
what are they Romans made it to South
America okay these aren't life on Mars
okay that'd be that'd be interesting
oracle bone writing okay what are they
what are they hiding on venus what are
what are they hiding on venus i'm
curious what are they hiding on venus
okay also also by the way we've already
hit the conspiracy theory now we're
going into the negative numbers or
positive the numbers have changed to
color here they go again
blink they're a different color now
because we're in beyond territory
what are they at wait what are they
hiding on Venus I'd like to talk about
one of the most mysterious and yet
seldomly spoken about objects in the
entire solar system and so you may be
asking yourself well what is so special
about planet Venus and before we go any
further and we get into the nitty-gritty
of no I want to know what of the
strangeness stop and so as I was
explaining at the beginning of the video
and many of you will probably
notice this - was that there has been
for years now what I have called a
blackout as it pertains to planet Venus
and our attention has always been placed
in the opposite direction whether it be
with visiting moons of Saturn or Jupiter
and specifically planet Mars and so is
there a blackout when it comes to planet
Venus why do we never hear about it and
is there a very good reason for that and
could it be that this mysterious planet
no Venus I'm going to show you ok where
is it hang on hold on here we go
the reason we don't go to Venus and we
have sent probes to Venus because
[ __ ] 462 degrees Celsius the pressure
is 9 point to the the the isn't the the
atmosphere is like sulfuric acid it's
not a cool place to go I mean it's a
cool place to go but I mean it's not a
fun place to go it's real cool at all it
not fun Buzz Aldrin we're all in danger
from evil at South Pole this was such a
huge news story and why hundreds of
thousands if not millions by now have
read it and have been again put into
fear having read it and are now worrying
about this and are emailing me wondering
what is going on and what I make of it
okay hang on we are all in danger it is
evil itself
snow is fat check No then you can't
trust nope
they're all covering up it's all part of
a conspiracy so I don't know how I
forget what the number actually is for
how many it took to get to a conspiracy
theory video but it wasn't a lot it was
not a lot
I went from metalworking I wanted to see
metalworking that was a the YouTube
rabbit hole I don't know what I'm going
to call this video but that was fun
and the amazing thing about YouTube is
that you can make whatever you want you
can upload whatever you want you can do
whatever you want like it's YouTube to
make videos and you can put them up
that's the
beauty of it but with the beauty comes a
little bit of evil and with YouTube the
challenge is how do you get someone to
the videos that they actually want to
see because most people don't know what
they want to see until they see it what
does that mean it should be so easy to
get to the conspiracy oh well I don't
know I don't know the answer to that one
but this was fun
- thank you everybody so much for
watching I might do this again just
because it's kind of fun just to see
where the rabbit hole goes how deep does
YouTube want you to dive like where does
it lead out no idea if you've gone to
any weird places on YouTube let me know
down in the comments below thank you
everybody so much for watching as always
I'll see you in the next one bye bye
[Music]
you